okay guys we want to talk about how to
speed up this whole Kido adaptation now
what's happening is you're going from
sugar fuel to fat fuel now let's look at
what's happening deep inside the cells
your body is running on sugar okay blood
sugar so it's dependent on mainly the
stored sugar in your muscle in your
liver which you don't have a lot of or
the the diet so you're like you have to
constantly eat to keep the sugars up so
now what we want to do is dependent on
the fat because we have a lot more fat
than we do stored sugar in fact we have
an average thin person has about seventy
seven thousand calories of stored fat so
this is a better quality of fuel but in
the transition phase you might have to
have a lowered blood sugar okay and this
is where people get uncomfortable so
there's some tips that you can do number
one always combine keto within a minute
fasting at the same time
don't do them separately they're both
powerful tools and strategies to drop
insulin to speed up the process because
if you do it have been fasting with too
much sugar too much carb you're going to
prolong the agony and never get into
ketosis because to get into ketosis you
need to drop your carbs okay but
intimate fasting works because you're
not eating as frequent and you're going
to drop insulin so if you're just doing
keto and you're doing multiple meals
realize every time you eat you spike
insulin and again you're it's going to
take longer to get into this adaptation
where your body has cellular machines
that are burning fat full time okay so
you basically have to drop this way down
to the point where your body is like
looking for fuel if you can't find it so
it's going to go after the fat and then
it's going to pray if you do this
correctly it'd be like three days maybe
four days and then you'll you'll be like
80% in ketosis but sometimes it takes
longer which I'll cover in a second but
the point is
it'll happen like gradual gradual
gradual now there's going to be a point
where you're going to be between meals
we are really really hungry okay so you
have to do
I ate a mild hunger which you just push
through or intense hunger where it's
like really severe in which case we
don't want to add more stress to your
body so don't suffer through that just
add a small snack which is only fat
don't add protein add fat because if
protein will stimulate more insulin fat
will stimulate a little insulin but not
as much as protein because as soon as
you eat the protein you're gonna feel
better and that's going to crash down
now you're going to be hungry again so
do fat maybe you do
pecans which is a real fatty nut or an
avocado but just do a little fat just to
get you through the transition and the
other thing is if you're going from one
meal to the next it's very very
important to have enough fat to satisfy
you so if you're like hurting and you're
really suffering make sure the next meal
you add more fat so that's one thing
which is right here but also add more
greens more salad and vegetables because
the potassium will actually heal the
insulin and it helps stabilize the blood
sugar at the cellular level so we need
those minerals to really speed this
process up okay the other thing is
outside of vinegar with lemon do a
tablespoon and a tablespoon of lemon and
some water take a straw so it doesn't
bother your teeth sip it down that will
actually speed things up to electrolytes
with large amounts of potassium and
nutritional yeast also will speed things
up because that heals the the deeper
root problem which is insulin resistance
so basically in the transition phase
you're really dealing with a below blood
sugar situation and what's behind that
is your body has not fully adapted so
all of these things are going to help so
go ahead and apply it and put your
comments down below
press the subscribe button and I will
keep you updated on the future events